the machine just keeps coming top down
here is Joe Biden the elderly man with
dementia who sniffed little girl's hair
the guy who's pretending to be president
but clearly is not pulling the strings
here he is at a Pride Celebration this
past weekend
it's wrong that extreme officials are
pushing hateful bills targeting
transgender children terrifying families
and criminalizing doctors
these are our kids these are our
neighbors this cruel this callous not
somebody else's kids they're all our
kids no you old win bag they're the
parents kids that's all my kids are not
your kids okay I don't understand how
anyone could think anything other also
the uh idea that somehow the government
should come in and force this which is
what they're trying to do in California
and that Joe Biden I mean mind muddled
stammering
buffoon Joe Biden thinks that it is the
government's purview to have anything to
do with any of this okay so what states
are doing you know it it's happening it
started here in Florida but now it's
happening in a whole bunch of other
states they are saying if you perform
these surgeries on kids if you
chemically castrate children think about
what that is if you give kids drugs that
stop their natural hormonal processes
you will lose your license and you will
possibly end up in jail now if you do it
as an adult meaning they are now 18 or
whatever the legal age is in that state
then so be it right and this is what a
mature society would do but it's not
just that Joe Biden is just saying it
he's celebrating it and he's really
pushing to legally Advance it at every
level and scare the hell out of
everybody who pushes against it we have
to act as a nation
we need to push back against the
hundreds of callus and cynical bills and
laws introduced in States targeting
transgender children
terrifying families and criminalizing
doctors and nurses these bills and laws
attack the most basic values and
freedoms we have As Americans that's not
hyperbole that's a fact
no it's hyperbole it's not a fact you
buffoon uh we did a bunch of searching
for these hundreds of evil bills and
here's what we came up with
crickets people crickets there are no
anti-lgbtq bills there are no bills to
stop gay people from doing everything
straight people can do there are no
bills to stop lesbians from playing
rugby or bisexuals from turning their
hair purple or trans people from doing
anything they want to do again this is
about
chemically castrating children and for
some reason that elderly man with
dementia is really into it this year
we're committing more Mental Health
Resources and new funding for programs
to help family support and affirm their
kids
a new federal initiative to address the
lgbq homelessness
the lgbq homeless first up he just got
rid of the tea there right I like how he
just forgot about the t's all together
but lgbq homelessness you know what the
problem is because these gays have very
high taste so you try to take a poor gay
person a homeless gay person you put
them into just some average hotel room
and they're like I can't look at those
blinds I can't live in this place it's
all so stupid
[Music]